economía en directo América de France 24
Jorge Hurtado ya está con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge buena mañana de miércoles
iniciamos entonces dando seguimiento a
las reacciones tras el mini presupuesto
del nuevo gobierno británico Como así
que un Mini presupuesto empecemos a
hablar de las reacciones inmediatas la
libra esterlina volvió a caer en los
mercados de Divisas luego de que el
fondo monetario internacional de agencia
calificadora muris criticaron esta nueva
estrategia económica de Reino Unido los
inversores se preparaban para un nuevo
golpe en los mercados de bonos que ya
obliga al banco de Inglaterra a prometer
medidas significativas ahora las
declaraciones del fondo monetario
internacional y demuris ponen más
presión sobre el nuevo ministro casawi
quarting para que reconsidere su
política o este presupuesto mini
presupuesto como también se le llama
allá en Reino Unido el fmi dice que la
naturaleza de estas medidas en Reino
Unido probablemente aumentará la
desigualdad esto porque se reduce el 45
45% al 40% la banda más alta del
impuesto sobre la renta y se elimina la
subida prevista del impuesto de
sociedades y el tope a los bonos de los
banqueros el organismo multilateral dijo
que está siguiendo las medidas del
gobierno británico y los instó inclusive
a modificar su programa de crecimiento
basado en grandes recortes de impuestos
junto con medidas para aumentar la
productividad leemos un fragmento de
esto que decía el fondo monetario
internacional
dadas las elevadas presiones
inflacionarias en muchos países incluido
el Reino Unido no recomendamos en este
momento paquetes Fiscales grandes y sin
objetivos específicos pues es importante
que la política fiscal no funcione de
forma contraria la política monetaria
ahora Jorge que dijo al respecto la
agencia calificadora muris o un reporte
bastante contundente según la agencia de
los planes de recortes Fiscales sin
financiación podrían dar lugar a mayores
déficit presupuestarios y aún aumento de
los tipos de interés amenazando la
credibilidad del país ante los
inversores el comunicado afirma que los
grandes recortes sin financiación eran
negativos para el crédito ya que
conducirían a déficit estructuralmente
más altos en un contexto de aumento de
Los costos del endeudamiento una
perspectiva de crecimiento más débil y
una aguda presión del gasto público el
estímulo fiscal financiado por la deuda
aumentaría la inflación que de por sí ya
está alta especialmente si la libra
esterlina se mantiene cerca de sus
mínimos históricos leemos también parte
de lo que decía esta agencia
un choque de confianza sostenido
derivado de las preocupaciones del
mercado sobre la credibilidad de la
estrategia fiscal del gobierno que se
tradujeran unos costos de financiación
estructuralmente más altos podría
debilitar de forma más permanente la
asequibilidad de la deuda del Reino
Unido ahora Jorge cambiamos información
porque la vicepresidenta de Estados
Unidos kamala Harris aseguró que Japón y
su país cooperarán para impulsar la
producción de Microchips Harry dice que
su administración Busca nuevas
inversiones para Estados Unidos la gira
en Tokio muestra el interés de Estados
Unidos para impulsar la fabricación de
semiconductores y ampliar la cadena de
suministros de materiales críticos la
vulnerabilidad de la economía las
interrupciones en el flujo de los chips
informáticos evidenció durante la
pandemia cuando la escasez aumentó Los
costos y paralizó también el ensamblaje
de vehículos y otros productos
electrónicos actualmente china está
invirtiendo en la producción de chips
mientras Estados Unidos aprobó un
millonario paquete para aumentar la
producción local así consolidar sus
relaciones tecnológicas con países como
Corea del Sur Taiwán y Japón la ley que
aprobó Estados Unidos hace disponible
unos 52 mil millones de dólares para
subvenciones e incentivos a las empresas
de semiconductores además de un crédito
fiscal del 25% cuando inviertan en
instalaciones en Estados Unidos para
producir estos chips que son esenciales
por ejemplo para encender el radio para
subir la ventana para poner el aire
acondicionado de un vehículo bueno
absolutamente casi todo para utilizarlo
en las óptimas condiciones Jorge
naciones unidades vertical el cuerno de
África está al borde de una hambruna por
segunda vez en poco más de una década Y
es que un funcionario de este organismo
afirma que somalia está en un una grave
situación después de cuatro años de
sequía que terminaron con todo el ganado
del que dependen muchas personas allí
hay 200.000 personas en peligro de morir
de hambre aseguró haber Gabriel
representante regional para África de la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas para
la agricultura y la alimentación el
funcionario dijo que busca ayudar a los
campesinos de la región etíope de tigrey
donde los Rebeldes están luchando de
nuevo contra la fuerza gubernamentales
escuchamos
muchas personas en somalia dependen de
la ganadería para su sustento y es esto
lo que han estado perdiendo De hecho no
solo en somalia en el cuerno de África
en general que abarca Kenia Etiopía
principalmente somalia ha habido un
grave grave problema
de momento nos venimos Jorge a nuestra
región latinoamericana vamos a Argentina
específicamente donde organizaciones
sociales acamparon acamparon y lo
hicieron frente al Ministerio de
desarrollo social en Buenos Aires en
protesta por las medidas económicas del
Gobierno de Alberto Fernández la unidad
piquetera y movimientos sociales se
instalaron frente al ministerio para
exigir la apertura de nuevas
asignaciones y más asistencia
alimentaria los manifestantes
prometieron quedarse por tiempo
contenido de no recibir una respuesta el
receptor principal de los
cuestionamientos es el Ministerio de
desarrollo social que conduce Juan
Zabaleta ese organismo es el que aprueba
las políticas de asistencia social Pero
han dicho que no abrirán mayores planes
de ayuda al menos Durante este año los
manifestantes piden nuevos planes
sociales así como más beneficiarios y
exigen mejorar la periodicidad y entrega
de los alimentos Parece que la
renovación de las relaciones digamos
diplomáticas completas con Venezuela y
Colombia Jorge no están del todo bien
porque Venezuela pidió suspender los
vuelos Bogotá Caracas Y es que tras la
reanudación de la frontera entre ambos
países se esperaba también una
reactivación de los vuelos a ese país el
4 de octubre a Venezuela específicamente
desde el sábado Se suspendió
inesperadamente la venta de los boletos
causando algunas molestias en los
usuarios la suspensión fue una solicitud
del gobierno venezolano según la la
aerolínea wingo los boletos para ir a
Venezuela se suspendieron después de que
se conociera también que el venezolana
conviasa no podía viajar a Colombia por
las sanciones internacionales en su
contra de esta forma la reapertura de
fronteras entre ambos países no fue
acompañada por la reapertura aérea como
estaba contemplado bueno Lamentablemente
Jorge esperemos que todo se solucione
para que las personas que quieran viajar
a Caracas desde Bogotá lo pueden hacer
sin ningún inconveniente Gracias Jorge
por toda la información de economía más
adelante más por supuesto pasamos a
saludar a Luis Méndez que tiene toda la
actualidad de los deportes
[Música]